[Music]
and one thing that i definitely notice
about myself is the pattern that i
seem to always cheat on every
relationship that i'm on since says 20.
you're pretty lonely guy is that fair
yeah and so loneliness
exacerbates what you're experiencing
[Music]
hey uh
what's up this is john with the dr john
dolone
show we talk about your mental health
your wellness
your marriage your friendships going on
dates education what's going on in this
classroom these days with your kids
whatever we can do talking to first
responders we're talking to everybody
if you want to be on the show we'd love
to have you give us a shout at
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to johndaloni.com
ask ask
and this little web form will show up
like it's 1987 and you can fill out the
web form and it will go to
kelly's electronic communication box
emails at what kids call it these days
and we will get you on the show super
excited all right let's go to ethan in
chinatown what's up ethan
hey dr john how are you i'm good my
brother what's going on with you
uh not much a little nervous sorry i've
never done anything like this before so
hey listen
i'm
i'm terrible at this and so when people
hear it they'll be like who is that guy
and they're talking about me not you so
you're good to go man so what's up okay
good to know uh so um i am a first
responder uh in chicago what's your gig
man and
i'm a police officer excellent um yep
you're a typical b cop
i'm grateful for you man thank you
thank you sir appreciate it um so
i the reason i'm calling this is because
over the past
i don't know maybe like a year or so
i've been feeling a lot of like
ups and downs they're
much more defined to a point where like
i've
like i've noticed it um
and uh i guess uh the past month um i
guess now my ex-girlfriend uh caught me
uh cheating on her
and uh so obviously that absolutely did
not help whatsoever with my situation
and actually made it worse
and uh so it made me reflect a lot about
you know everything that's been going on
and one thing that i definitely notice
about myself is the pattern that i
seem to always cheat on every
relationship that i'm on since
just 20.
i'm now uh 37 and so
i've only had like you know five major
relationships but it seems like
i find one uh i'm really into them uh
feels great i feel like i'm in love with
them and then
somewhere along the line i cheat and
and eventually i
i feel like i no longer want to be there
but
then i don't want to break it off and
and i guess i just make things worse so
like they can just leave me yeah and so
i've never been caught uh this was
actually the first time
and uh
so it like say it made me feel worse for
the fact that i i hurt her so bad yeah
um so i just like said it just seems
like everything is just like collapsing
around me and it's just like
trying to find a way out and reason like
why do i keep doing knowing that i know
it's wrong why do i keep doing stuff
like this and you know i guess you know
like as you really know i i've heard you
mentioned that your father was a police
officer you know that the job is
stressing i i didn't realize like i
always thought like well it's not a big
deal i see this stuff or whatever move
on but all of a sudden things are just
kind of like coming back to me and i'm
like why is this
why am i thinking about this uh scenario
or that event and yeah i just yeah sorry
hey man that's good i appreciate that so
number one thanks for your honesty uh it
takes a lot of courage number two
um
you 37 so how long you've been in
uh i've been in total uh
going on 90 years now okay so you're
almost a decade and you know as well as
i do that culture
is heavy on keep your mouth shut and do
your job right so the fact that you made
this call
is an act of
bravery
that um unfortunately many of your
colleagues don't have the courage to
summon so um um i'm proud of you there
okay so you've presented two different
issues that may intertwine here and
there but but let's separate them a
little bit okay
okay one of these is to quote the old
vanderkult book
the body keeps the score
and
there's only so long you can work the
beat
and for most people
in our country probably in the world
they have no idea
what's going on in their neighborhoods
after hours right right no zero none
and have no idea that guy they see out
mowing the yard had the cops called on
him at 2 am by his girlfriend because he
was beating her like they have no idea
the dead body and the in the
emmy shows up at 3 30 in the morning and
nobody even knows what happened right
and so and you do that all day
every day day after day after day after
day and you have to show up to a
situation and here's the deal in the new
world you have to be perfect
you better be perfect right yeah and so
because everything you do is now
recorded audio video everything be
perfect question everything that's right
that's right
um so
um
what i would
strongly encourage you to do
and when i say strongly encourage you
i'm just telling you just like friend to
friend you have to
you gotta go sit down and tell somebody
and i absolutely understand that this
cannot be somebody associated with your
work and if that's the case um i'd
recommend you go find somebody
not insurance figure out find pay the
cash and so there's not a diagnostic
record and sit down with somebody and
say hey uh this thing's starting to wear
on me it's not i'm not okay okay um and
they're gonna walk you through it
i was fortunate when i had a i was part
of a patrol team and but i had a every
time i'd get out of a messy situation
right like cleaning up a scene before a
mom came home right or
um helping move a body before so and so
showed up before sister got there right
when i was a part of those situations i
was blessed with a supervisor that would
call every time and say how are you
you okay
walk me through what you saw and what i
didn't get at the time was there was a
processing going from limbic to frontal
lobe to to
simplify it which is letting my body
know you just experienced some stuff
that was chaos man you just saw guts and
brains and blood and people you just saw
somebody tell their child that their
dads did like you just saw some stuff
you're not supposed to see
and i need to make you make sure you're
with us here that you your body knows
you're safe right now and right now your
body because this is what you do all day
every day and probably
you're pretty lonely guy is that fair
yeah
yeah yeah i just had to admit to that
it's hard is that it's hard it's hard
and so loneliness
exacerbates what you're experiencing
because your brain needs human beings
and what happens a lot with lawyers it
happens a lot with doctors it happens a
lot with cops
is nobody understands their world
because it's so chaotic it's just such
so different than the norm
that you end up hanging out with only
cops
yeah then y'all when you're not working
you're talking about working i can't
believe sergeant's moving us to twelves
instead of tens and i can't right all
that's all you do man they're
technicians
yeah dude and we're going from six to
glocks that's ridiculous
and it's just non-stop it never quits
and so you your brain never gets to
watch the sun freaking come up or to try
and even even when oh sorry even when i
try to hang out with like civilians or
non-cops they they always ask me those
stupid questions you know like yeah shot
anybody
yeah right absolutely it's tiring it is
it is and so
the re-entry program when you meet
people they're going to ask you those
those dumb series of questions the worst
is when veterans come home right did you
kill anybody do you shoot your body
right and you get that all the time too
it's
learning and this is gonna sound
ridiculous the same as when they took
you to marksman classes
you're gonna have to learn a new set of
skills and here's why that sucks because
when we were kids dude they just dropped
us all in a box and said y'all play and
we did they put us on the same kickball
field they're on the same football team
we're on the same whatever and we just
figured it out
and when we're older and we're adults we
don't have that skill set skill set's
gone it's we've lost it
and in the same way you can't just go
pick up and run a marathon right now
uh
you can't just pick up and become best
brothers with somebody you have to it's
annoying and it's long and it's she has
to slog through especially those first
four or five awkward moments and this is
the pot talking to the kettle man i'm a
lonely guy too right i'm having to
practice friendship and that sounds
stupid all right so that's number one
number one is you gotta go talk to
somebody okay you're okay you are ripe
for making a
a
a poor decision
because your your body's trigger is
really really tight right now
okay okay you're gonna not show up
you're gonna miss a call you're gonna go
sit down and all of a sudden you've been
in the restaurant having a burger on
shift for 45 minutes and you've missed
three calls in the car right it's going
to happen right right
or you're going to get on scene and
you're going to snap at somebody who's
just trying to figure out to do the next
how they can do the next right thing
that's my fear it is right and so i'm
telling you your body's getting close
and i want you to go talk to somebody
okay hopefully you have a
sergeant that has passed along how
important this stuff is and that you'll
have a culture in your unit of
being open and this stuff not coming
back to bite you during annual reviews
or get you put on a desk for a time
hopefully you've got a
supportive but most police departments
in the country don't have that yet
they're getting there people are moving
there's a lot of shifting and changing
and it's beautiful to see but most
people aren't there yet if it's not go
see somebody
here's part two
how long
have you looked in the mirror and said
i'm not enough
um
your whole damn life
since i can remember
where'd you learn that who told you that
um
it would sometimes uh come from
my uh
from my dad and from just uh my uh
childhood time in school okay i got i
got uh bullied a lot uh i got picked on
for like the dumbest things like the
color of my eyes
or my smile or or something like my
shoes
so
yeah you got picked on and how did you
how did your old man respond to that
um
honestly i wish he would have responded
it seemed like
he him and my mom was still married but
uh i always felt like
he was far away even though he was here
at home
um
most of the time i just remember him
like just
watching tv and just not really caring
about what was going on and if something
would happen he might say something here
and there but
it never felt like he truly
cared and wanted to show me how to
defend myself or
or protect me or anything like that it
just seemed like like i said he was he
was home but he just was not here that's
how i felt he's six feet apart but six
thousand miles away from you right
absolutely yeah hey here's the thing and
i don't have any evidence to back this
up other than just sitting with
countless people over the years
i think there can be as much if not more
trauma
than if he had just left
because when he just left then you got
to deal with it but when they just sit
there
and by the way trauma can be acute it
could be the you walk into the house and
you see part of that person blown all
over that wall that's trauma when you're
hugging a mom who's holding you so tight
because her baby's dead in the next room
that's trauma right
trauma can be acute and
trauma can be what didn't happen
and your dad should have looked at you
in the eye and said i love you son i'm
so sorry this happens give me a hug
right that should have happened and it
didn't now here's the problem
you've spent your life trying to answer
that question
trying to make it so
and when you find somebody as some sort
of conquest
tell me if i'm wrong a few months in
you get bored
to quote the great ester perel you stop
feeling alive
this has nothing to do with the women
you're with this has everything to do
with you
and you make a choice to not be alive
and the only thing to get your heart
rate up
is i'm not getting caught
this new person caught my eye and then
in short order you blow the whole thing
up and then you control all delete and
start the whole cycle over again am i
right
yeah literally you know it's like you've
been like you know me
but yeah
so listen
the only way to stop cheating is to say
i will never cheat again
okay and what i'll tell you is you're
better than that and the women that
didn't catch you
you
you made them crazy because they knew
there was a disconnection and you know
what they did they thought it was them
and that's not that's wrong it's not
right that's true
right
and they walk around now wondering what
they did why that man couldn't love them
and it probably fulfilled a story that
they've been passing along for their
whole lives right that they've been
they've been spinning around so
and so i am getting on to you stop stop
yeah okay
you have a choice in every relationship
and we all do i've been married almost
20 years i've got the same thing
i have to choose how do i remain alive
in this
relationship and not alive like i'm
dying my wife's not suffocating me how
do i keep my heart rate up how do i keep
this exciting how do i keep this fun how
do i help meet her needs so she can help
meet my needs and we just get on the
loop like that
not
how can i prop up this shallow thin ego
because nobody ever told me i was worth
the crap
you see what i'm saying
yeah no it makes it makes a lot of sense
okay
so again
this is looping back to
when you make that call today you're
gonna look you're gonna get on the phone
and you're gonna be brave as i'll get
out like you are right now and you're
gonna call a counselor and they're gonna
say hey what's up and you're gonna say
i'm a police officer
i'm worried about confidentiality
i'm
starting to have signs of of excessive
stress and burnout from my job it's hard
and i need to talk to somebody and
i'm a serial cheater
and i've got i want to stop
and that's where we're going to go okay
okay
and listen brother
hear me say this because nobody's ever
told you this
i'm a six foot two 200 pound 195 pound
guy okay i can't shoot as well as you
and you could probably beat me up
especially if you're wearing all your
gear and if you got maze for sure
but listen
i love you
and you're worth being loved back
thank you
grateful for the work you do in your
community the crap that you see and you
deal with 24 7 365 that nobody sees and
i'm glad that you don't want to put
yourself in a situation where you're
going to hurt somebody
yeah
and
you're better than the way you're acting
you can do better both hand right
yep all right exactly thank you so much
listen hang on the line i'm going to
send you a copy of new book on your past
change your future i'm sending a bunch
out to um the local uh police department
here in my community um
i i think it'll help a lot you've been
through a lot you've seen a lot and then
the question we all have to ask
ourselves is what do we do next and this
book addresses it i'm gonna give it to
you free of charge i'm grateful for you
man your new day starts
right now we'll be right back
[Music]
hey john deloney here i say it all the
time there are no tips or tricks or
hacks when it comes to living a better
life it all comes down to being
intentional with the practices you do
every day and the most important
practice you can do to improve your
mental and physical health is to start
getting enough quality sleep i know this
from personal experience and from the
data and for me good sleep starts with a
world-class mattress it's why my family
sleeps on dream cloud mattresses whether
you're a back sleeper a stomach sleeper
an edge of the bed sleeper or just a
weird sleeper right or you have to make
room for your dog dream cloud's combo of
gel memory foam and coil technology
keeps you comfortable all night and
dream cloud is running their biggest
offer ever exclusively for our listeners
499 dollars in accessories plus an
additional 250 discount that's a total
of
749 in accessories and savings pillows
mattress protector luxury sheets all of
it it's time to change your sleep and
change your life visit
dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get your new savings and your
new mattress today
all right hey we're back hey don't
forget
go to the internet
and if you uh watch us on youtube please
subscribe and
if you let's do it on podcast please
subscribe there too and i also learned
this the other day
this is so great
um
you can leave reviews did you know that
oh i knew that yeah i didn't hey leave
reviews all positive ones if you have
negative reviews just email them to
james directly
and uh otherwise leave positive reviews
is that how you're supposed to do this
actually tell you what you tell what you
really think but yeah leave reviews man
i didn't i didn't know you could do that
every time i buy something online they
always say like hey would you like to
review and i'm like
no i gave you money for the mower that's
that's that's cool anyway
is that a good thing
yeah that's great i mean most people
that leave reviews only have negative
you know like you tend to not leave a
review unless you have a really bad
experience all the stars all of the
stars
all of them and if you have less than
all of them
email james directly he loves negative
feedback all right let's go to uh
anthony in atlanta georgia what's up
brother anthony
what's going on doc how are we doing
fantastic man uh thank you for the call
you got it man what's up
so um i'm in a job that i think
i
was i think i was made for it i think i
love it at its core
but recently
it's been really difficult um and it's
just kind of sucked and i think a lot of
other people who are in this job
think the same thing
um can i guess
go ahead either police officer nurse or
teacher
the last one you got yeah dude fantastic
yeah what grade you teach
what do you teach um
so i teach middle school spanish oh man
hola me llamo juan como estas
mucho gusto
muy bien
uh
good man so obviously you had a teacher
that taught you something right
i grew up in houston
and my dad was fluent in spanish and he
just he would talk to me in spanish and
he would say funny things to me so i had
to learn it's just part of it but it's
cool yes i did i did have great spanish
teachers by the way
awesome senora perez she was awesome
badass she's good all right so yeah all
right
done with that okay we're on to the next
so how can i help man yeah so
i guess my question is at what point
should i look for something else
um
and like
at what point should i say okay this is
hard
it's supposed to be hard
it's kind of hard in a good way
um but at what point should it just be
like this is not i have to find
something else or move to a different
district or something like that
great question man that's a question on
everybody's heart mind right now across
the country and that's in almost every
job right now you can you can see the
stats people are just quitting and
leaving what they call the great
resignation um
what else is going on in your life do
you have other stuff going on or is the
i can hear it on you is this all job
related
um
i probably have some other stuff i'm
currently doing my masters
um
and i probably have some stuff i'm in
graduate school continue
i have a
son who turned two in february
yup continue and
me and my wife are in our 30 years
marriage
dude
so
um uh this is gonna be spoiler alert you
have a lot going on and then you get
home from work and you have
more going on
right yeah
for sure that's a lot a lot a lot a lot
okay
so first and foremost you have a brand
new marriage
brand new
and
it sounds like y'all had like a cool fun
reckless nine or ten months and then she
got pregnant right
not even yeah
look at you you're like not even man
and so now you're trying to figure out
how to be married
trying to figure out how to change a
thousand diapers a day literally i
thought kids pooped once a week i had no
idea it was 10 diapers a day
and you're trying to do all that at the
same time and you're in grad school are
you doing online courses are you having
to go to class in the evenings
luckily everything is online okay well
here's the thing luckily and not luckily
because luckily you're all online
but that means you're around everybody
right and i loved loved my programs
being in person because i had to unplug
from home and go i could plug fully into
my school work when you have online
courses and a two-year-old and a
three-year marriage three-year-old
marriage
you're not really anywhere ever right
yeah you're kind of at school scratching
out assignments and you're kind of
hugging a kid and you're kind of like
hey can you come help me with this and
you're so you're kind of parent you're
kind of husbanding right both all of it
yeah
and then stinking emails dude
they never quit and any kid who gets a d
is clearly because you suck at your job
right
you understand yeah and it's not even
worth failing the kid like it the
paperwork and the complaints and having
to justify it to your print it's not
even worth it i'm just going to give you
a d because i don't want to fight you
right
over yes and over again
and so
here's the deal your body is paying the
price and it's exhausted this is the
cornerstone right
like from the great nygotsky sisters
it's deep exhaustion
depersonalization like you kind of just
stopped caring how long you've been
teaching
since my second year okay at the start
of year one tell me if i'm wrong you
were gonna help you were gonna be the
teacher that helped him learn a second
language everyone needs to know a second
language how do you not know a second
language and we're in georgia learning
spanish is beautiful it's gonna help you
be hospitable and communicate with your
neighbors it's gonna be great and i'm
gonna be the teacher and then here you
are two years in and you're like yeah
whatever
to get your assignments in right yeah
yes absolutely is that fair okay and the
third part of this is futility
what i'm doing literally doesn't matter
because none of these moronic kids even
care
yeah and that's kind of where my head
has been i think and that that's kind of
what's been the most difficult this
second half of this year is i feel like
okay i'm showing up every day i'm
putting my best foot forward i'm doing
my masters and then at the end of the
lesson the kids literally don't care at
all yeah
and so it's like
you know
is that my job is my job to show up and
be a light and go home and then come
back the next day
um i just don't really feel like
i'm building anything yet okay um and
that's kind of difficult absolutely so
your body's burnt out
and
public school you a public school
yes public schools and private schools
forget what that all schools have been
an absolute zoo the last 24 36 months
okay
yeah so i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you a
story that happened to me and then i'll
answer your your question on the back
end okay
um
i was working at a university and i had
somebody that i had high high trust in
somebody that i
spoke into my life on spiritual matters
has spoken in my life on professional
and personal matters i had high trust
the person is about 10 or 15 years older
than me very wise and brilliant
there was a student situation and the
student was not being treated with i
thought dignity and respect to the point
that i thought i don't think i can work
here anymore
and
i trusted this person's wisdom and i
also am a hothead and so i know that
before i do drastic things i'm gonna go
sit down and talk to somebody
so i sat down with this person and
explained everything this is what's
happening this is the pattern i've seen
with a wide swath of students and in
this particular case here's here's the
part where i think i've got to draw a
line
and he patiently listened and here's
what he said and a he screwed me up
forever and he changed the trajectory of
my professional life with this one
statement okay
he said
based on what you've told me john you're
free to go
you're free to go what's happening is
wrong
what's happening is shouldn't be this
way and there should be some changes etc
you're free to go
and then he followed up with this state
this sentence
but i want you to never forget
the moment you walk out that door these
students will still be here
and if everybody who cares leaves
the students are on their own
and i looked at him and said dude i hate
you
i hate you right
and yeah from that moment my mission
shifted
i then said where can i find places
where i can enter into the messiest of
situations
the hardest situations the ones that
make me the most uncomfortable where
people like me are stuck in these
situations in these systems how can i
enter into those spaces
and how can i turn a light on and here's
what had to happen
i can only do that
if my body's okay if i'm well if i've
got relationships so here's my guess
you have an exhausted wife and you're
exhausted and you're half present and
half not and you have a two-year-old
that just goes
all the
time and yeah your sex life's a mess or
at least not what you had in your mind
and pictured in your mind
you've because you're so busy you're
stopped hanging out very regularly with
any group of guy friends
you're pretty lonely
you have no hobbies other than the
stupid master's degree and trying to
grade papers and respond to pissed off
parent emails and they don't even know
spanish
and and and and and it probably cuts in
on your workout time it probably cuts in
on the right and it's easier just to
grab something on the way home from work
do you see what i'm getting at
yes absolutely you have to provide an
ecosystem for your body to be well what
does that look like you must have
friends you got to have guy friends that
you leave and your wife's going to say
hey you're not here enough as it is
you have to have that
you have to
step back and say hey we our marriage is
happening in real time
i don't like where it's headed she
doesn't like where it's headed let's sit
down and say all right they were three
years in let's let's do the good the bad
and ugly we may not even go see somebody
not because it's broken not because
but this is the recipe for how one tiny
little inch apart becomes five feet
becomes ten feet becomes ten thousand
miles in ten years right yeah
how can i
start leaving the house for my grad
school stuff so i can unplug i'm gonna
go to a local coffee shop i'm gonna go
to a local fill in the blank i'm gonna
do it at my office at school so that
when i'm home i can be fully home
even if that means i come home at eight
o'clock on those nights or nine o'clock
on those nights that's fine
because when i'm there i'm fully there
how can i put an exercise program how
can i make sure i'm starting to sleep
how can i have some boundaries at school
and those things you take care of those
things and your body begins to go
and then you have the strength and power
and creativity returns and you can enter
into that chaotic school and say all
right y'all don't care it's my job as
your teacher to figure out how to make
this stuff worth caring about
right how can i bring in people from the
community that speak spanish
that
i can show these folks what it looks
like when somebody lights up when you
speak to them and they're in their
native tongue what a gift right how can
i teach people
how to say thank you how to
talk about love how to talk about
connection how to talk about support and
health and care how can i do these
things and communicate the importance of
language how can i do some of that and
when your body's in fight or flight
brother you can't
but when it's at peace and i'm not
saying you're not busy you're still
crazy town busy right
right but you're well in your busyness
hear what i'm saying
absolutely okay so to answer your
original question
how do you know when it's time to leave
here's my
here's the story i tell myself
i don't run from things anymore i go two
things
so in the rare situation that i have to
transition like i've got a poor leader
somebody's unethical some and i have to
leave this situation i'm gonna go to a
thing
see what i'm saying i'm not gonna run
from because the sucky part about
running is that where you ever you end
up you go with
you yeah and so you're exhausted burnt
out fried frazzled marriage exhausted
two-year-old dad is in grad school that
guy's gonna show up at the other school
district and at the other school
district under the other school district
and
parents are parents brother kids are
kids you know that
yeah and so it may be that you have a
sucky leadership system at your school
that's for real that happens i've seen
those i've talked to those folks it's
real and it may be that you need to
change places
but go to something
not from something is that does that
make sense that sounds like a trite
little thing you you stitch on a pillow
i get that but you hear what i'm saying
absolutely and uh yeah yeah all right so
your homework today
you like what i did that teacher your
homework today is to sit down and say
where are the areas i'm not well where
are the areas i'm not whole
and how do i begin to backfill those
things and most of that conversation is
going to take place with your wife it
probably starts with this hey honey i'm
not okay
i've put too much into the to the bowl
here and i'm not okay
can you help me begin to walk through
this and she'll probably have a great
insight into yeah you don't sleep man or
now you started snoring or now you've
really started snapping at such and such
and i miss you and all those things
y'all can begin to work on this together
i'm going to send you a copy of my new
book too um it'll help walk you through
that and i'll do it for your charts head
on the line and kelly will get your info
and she'll send it to you
thank you for heading into middle
schools every day into the battle zone
thank you for trying to learn more and
being a continuing student thank you for
trying to be a good dad a good husband
look in the mirror say that guy's worth
taking care of that guy's worth loving
and begin to build that world we'll be
right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert and a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right hey we're back and hey shout
out to teachers um last caller anthony's
a middle school spanish teacher who
loves it he says his dream job for all
teachers all year long you've been
grinding out to make sure your students
are actually learning despite all the
distractions
you work so hard and like anthony you
care even harder
and there's teachers like you that have
taught our foundations and personal
finance curriculum to teach people how
things that our government doesn't know
which is how dollars work and how math
works and how uh
debt works right
changed the lives of over five million
students teachers like anthony who are
going every day and trying to make a
difference in the lives of these
students hey at where i work here at
ramsey solutions in my personal heart
i've been a teacher my wife's been a
teacher my mom dad teacher's like that's
just who our family is
we love teachers and so here at ramsey
solutions we're going to give away
we can't solve your problems we're going
to give away cash
so go to ramseysolutions.com teacher for
a chance to win
thousands and thousands of dollars
multiple teachers will win up to five
grand cash
it won't make everything better but man
it'll help just a little bit all right
go to randysolutions.com
teacher for a chance to win let's go to
emma in provo utah what's up emma
hi
oh nothing much just tired
welcome to 21st century what's up
so my brother has had a couple of felony
charges against him
and i want to know how to help my
pregnant sister-in-law um be a sport for
her
um she thinks it's some sort of scheme
against him
and
i know that i probably can't change her
mind but i want to be there for her
um but i don't want to like her to think
that i
believe that my brother is totally
innocent
okay so what did what what did your
brother do
well um he has a couple of charges that
have to do with a minor
he had to one charge that he was
pretending to be a minor and then that
he had some inappropriate conversations
with a minor online okay did he ever
connect with him in person
no okay that you know of right yeah yeah
that i know of no okay um
and you're you think he did this
i think yeah i think he could have done
it um it was really surprising for me
and
like i would have never guessed it but
there's other things that in their
relationship and other things that i've
heard from my siblings that make me
believe that he could have done this
so have you sat down with that and just
sat in it for a second that's hard
it is
i've tried to my my husband's like honey
you need to like work through this yeah
and then
just not try to get in his head because
i do that i try to get in people's heads
don't do that it's an absolutely waste
it's an absolute waste of your time and
it ends up poisoning your body literally
with the cortisol and adrenaline like
you it's don't do it
um your homework tonight before you even
get started i'll answer your other
question here i want you to write your
brother a letter that you're never going
to send him
okay
and i want you to be honest with him
about how pissed off you are
how angry you are that he screwed up the
whole family that he blew up his own
little marriage
that he hurt another child multiple
other children right i want you to be
honest in this letter okay
okay don't cut corners don't be like oh
what if you're not gonna send it to him
this letter is for you
okay
okay
and if possible i'd love for you to read
it out loud to your husband
you've heard me say this before it's
from the great david kessler grief
demands a witness
somebody has to sit with you
as much as that sucks and your brother
has blown up everything
yeah right
yeah and when people blow up everything
a couple of things happen either some
people rally around them and go it can't
be because i can't live in the world
that i've i'm now being asked to inhabit
which sounds like what your
sister-in-law is doing
yeah right or people
they are able to see oh no
or they deflect or they ignore kind of
like you've done like ah it's just i'm
just gonna ignore it and i'm just gonna
move on
everybody's just gotta sit in reality
right so we're not gonna get on to
sister
right now she is duct taping and
stringing and ribboning her life
together at the moment
yeah right it's it's exploded
yeah
and
uh she's she is in the situation that
i've been with when somebody's house
burns completely down and they're
heading home
and they say
they're told hey your house is in as a
total loss and you talk to them and they
say well i'm just gonna go by and see
what um what what's what what's what i
can grab what mem you know things are
left
and you say
hey it's all gone and they say yeah i
know but i'm like there's gonna be some
stuff that like they can't they can't
see that picture until they're in it
right that's where she's at yeah i don't
beat up people like that i don't go to
war with people like that their world is
a mess right
here's the hardest thing
has she asked for your help
no
and that
ah it's the worst
because you
your brother's a part of you and you
want to help make this thing right right
now you want to get in and start
sweeping up and cleaning up and
repainting so that everything can be as
it was and everything will never be as
it was
even if he's found not guilty coming
home as you mentioned there's some stuff
that needs to be discussed right
yeah and even if he's found guilty and
he gets 10 years because he didn't make
actual contact he gets five years and
pleads it down to two and he's on
probation whatever
everything's different now
yeah do you have your own kids
i do i have two boys
yeah and now you've already backed it up
and said
when did i leave him wait did he ever
right you've already been down that road
yeah right and every future engagement
every future family thing all that is is
screwed up now because of one person's
decisions and so you want to go fix it
and hear me say this and it breaks my
heart to say it out loud
you can't
it just is
and so the greatest gift you can give
your sister-in-law is to go see her in
person are you all close will she see
you
um i
don't know if she'll see me but she's
like an hour and a half away okay
um she's kind of mad at us
yeah that's fine that's fine um
taylor you love her
and tell her
you are here to walk alongside her any
way that you can
and that you're here and you and your
husband decide what does that mean
financially does that mean when they get
kicked out of the house because there's
no more income coming in or if it's
child care or if she has to move closer
to you guys so y'all can help keep the
baby while she's right whatever that
looks like
um y'all you and your husband decide
what your boundaries are gonna be and
then you let her know i'm here at any
time
and check in on her once a week but
don't insert yourself into her life if
she doesn't want you there because
that's not going to be supportive and
help that's about you trying to make
this thing a little less sucky for you
and it actually doesn't help her
yeah okay
maybe it's door dash we're going to send
you food once a week you don't have to
eat it but we just love you and we're
going to send you food once a week for
the next foreseeable future that might
be a thing y'all can do you know what i
mean and you can get with your other
brothers and sisters and say hey i'll
all do the food train we're going to
make sure they got a meal once a week
here's what you're doing you're playing
a long game now you're playing a 10-year
game a 15-year game
i want there to be a trail of
text messages and personal letters and
visits if possible and meals sent
we kept trying to show up for you and
for that little one we kept trying to
show up we kept trying to show up we
kept trying to show up
okay that's the game we're playing and
listen you have to grieve this i'm so
sorry
thanks
i know i've been avoiding it i know i
know and you have to i get it i get it i
get it i get it and it doesn't have to
be yeah it kind of needs to be soon let
it be soon okay
okay and when it washes over you it's
gonna be brutal
that's why you gotta do with other
people do you have a girlfriend or two
you can call that will come sit with you
yeah i do i do
maybe maybe give that a shot man i
maybe your husband's not the right guy
to read that letter to you somebody's
gotta sit down and listen to you
and hold you and hug you and
child abuse is so destructive to so many
people into those sweet sweet kids
who some reason had access to online
engagements
we'll be right back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
all right we are back hey um
this is super important and so i want to
read this
um this is
a shout out
i have a job where like i'm in front of
the microphone
and what most people will never
understand is that much of the show's
ideas and how it gets shaped and stuff
is because of kelly because of james
because of jenna all right right folks
who are helping with the calls and
helping craft like hey let's i want you
to talk about this i read this article
the other day most of the articles i
read are for geeks right and
um
james and kelly and ben they
speak like humans right and so
kelly came with to with with the idea of
hey i'm getting a lot of um a lot of
emails a lot of calls about suicide and
i want to do we need to do a suicide
show and even i was like man that seems
like a lot
um but it's one of the highest rated
shows we've ever done and the feedback
i've received from that show has been
extraordinary people are saying thank
you for talking about it thank you for
giving us some practical tips but this
is one note in particular and i won't
use the name because i didn't get
permission to but
here's a note that came in and
said this
i just want to say thank you for saving
a life
last night my wife's friend called and
was talking venting about her marriage
issues wasn't concerned that she's been
calling to vent at least weekly but
later that night she texted my wife some
dark things included that she had cut
her wrist but it wasn't that bad and
quote unquote i can't do this anymore
i'm embarrassed to say our first
instinct was she's probably not actually
trying to kill herself maybe this is
just for attention and this is just a
one-time thing
but i remembered a story you once told
of when you came upon a young man
sleeping who was actually attempting
suicide and you were unsure what to do
and all of a sudden a voice was in my
head screaming what are you doing call
9-1-1
i looked at my wife and said we don't
have a choice if you don't call i will i
was so nervous i've never called 9-1-1
before but i'm so relieved i did it
it turned out she had taken a whole
bottle of pills and slit her
throat and wrist repeatedly
she was taken to the hospital and is
okay now and getting the help she needs
from medical and psychological
professionals
thank you so much for encouraging me to
call even though i was unsure in the
moment and scared of the repercussions i
now know the risk of not calling is far
greater than the risk of calling
first and foremost
what a gift thank you for sending this
note
second
more globally
when in doubt call
somebody brings it up i shouldn't be
here anymore i don't want to be anymore
they start giving away their stuff that
surprise possessions to you when they
start saying things like hey i could cut
myself i cut my wrist it's not that big
of a deal or whatever i just take an
extra
call just call
just call and thirdly
many of you are at your job right now or
you're heading to your job and you don't
end up
at your job's equivalent of being on a
stage
you don't end up at you're not the one
who makes the final presentation you're
the person with ideas you're the person
supporting things you're just the person
creating things
so i can
put my name on a podcast or on a radio
show and put it out there and i'm the
guy talking
but this person's alive because of kelly
who did the work behind the scenes who
came up with the idea for this show and
put together the call list and made sure
everybody was comfortable they were
gonna call
this was an idea that started in the
heart of mind to somebody that's not in
front of the microphone
but that ended up saving a life two or
three people down the road
and i want to encourage you whatever
your job is
whether you're the teacher in front of
the classroom or you're the aide in that
classroom whether you are
the
wife who's the attorney who's getting
ready to uh
go defend um in court or you're the
husband who is the stay-at-home dad
making every sure everything
every body has a role to play everybody
everybody has a role to play what you do
is important
as my friend ken says what you do
matters
so thanks everybody thank you kelly for
this idea it's awesome
um
and thank you to this couple who called
thank you for everybody for listening to
the show so as we wrap up today's show
man it's the great the great ray
lamontagne
and here's a song you are the best thing
baby it's been a long day baby things
ain't been going my way and you know i
need you here to clear my mind all the
time and baby the way you move me it's
crazy it's like you see right through me
and make it easier believe me you don't
even have to try because
you're the best thing
you are the best
thing you're the best thing that ever
happened to me
baby we've come a long way baby you know
i hope and i pray that you believe me
when i say this love will never fade
away
because you
are the best thing
and to everybody listening y'all are the
best thing and i'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode this is
the best mental health podcast ever i am
wondering if it's okay
to completely disconnect and like
no longer have a relationship from my
sister so you don't want to hang out
with your sister anymore you want to cut
out of your life because of the way she
looks it's it's a factor
i mean i really want kids but i i
struggle
i'm also you know faith-based so i
struggle with divorce and leaving my
wife behind has she left you behind a
little bit in this decision yes she has
[Music]